How does soap work?
For well over a century, public health officials
have been pushing regular hand washing with
soap as one of the most effective methods
of inhibiting the spread of disease and infection.
The result of physical, as opposed to biological
processes, proper hand washing with regular
soap will thoroughly remove bacteria.
Yes, contrary to popular belief, soap just
helps remove microbes, it doesn’t kill them.
Throughout the day, your hands pick up bacteria
and viruses from a (surprisingly) wide variety
of objects.
Keyboards, especially at public stations,
are widely acknowledged to be filthier than
toilets square inch for square inch, as are
most smartphones and tablets.
That’s not to mention door handles, cash
and credit cards, or the common practice of
shaking hands when greeting someone you don’t
see often or have never previously met.
Even the paper towels in public restrooms
that you dry your hands with after washing
are commonly riddled with microbes spread
about from people flushing and the like.
Yes, microbes are quite literally everywhere,
though thankfully most are harmless to humans,
and some are even essential for our lives,
as well as certain types of tasty foods (see:
Humans and Our Love of Spoiled Foods).
Whatever the source, once picked up, both
harmless and harmful microbes stick to the
oil your hands naturally produce, and, absent
removal, willingly hitch a ride until they
reach their ultimate destination (inside of
you or somebody else) where they can in some
cases wreak havoc.
So how does the soap actually work to remove
the offending microbes if it doesn’t kill
them?
When you wash your hands with regular (as
opposed to antibacterial) soap and water,
the soap chemically works to break down the
oil, while the friction from rubbing does
it mechanically.
Thus, the more soap and the longer the hands
are rubbed together, once rinsed away with
water, the less oil and microbes left on your
hands.
Public health officials generally agree that
this method of hand washing, for at least
20 or more seconds at a time, is a highly
effective way of removing bacteria despite
the fact that the bacteria doesn’t die,
but is simply flushed away when you rinse
(or wiped off on a towel).
Those who prefer to kill the germs may turn
to antibacterial soap; however, it is only
marginally more effective than regular soap
(since the antibiotics in the soap only work
on a limited range of germs), and public health
experts, including the FDA, recommend against
antibacterial soap due to the likelihood that
its widespread use is contributing to the
increase in antimicrobial resistance.
Of course, even regular soap will be ineffective
if it’s contaminated, which is what often
happens with refillable dispensers; in a recent
study conducted in an elementary school, it
was discovered that more bacteria was found
on the hands of staff and students after they
washed with soap from contaminated dispensers
than before they ever touched them.